Disney's live-action Mulan is an epic action
film that's filled with tons of deep-cut references
to the original animation.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing 51 of the best Disney
easter eggs and hidden details to look out
for in the new movie, plus where to find the
secret tributes to Mushu.
Some spoilers ahead, so take care if you haven't
seen the movie yet.
The opening Disney logo has been transformed
with some cool new details appropriate to
Mulan.
The iconic fairy tale castle has been given
some Chinese-style architectural additions;
and then just behind that is a long wall,
a reference to the opening scene of the animated
movie where the Huns began their invasion
by scaling the Great Wall of China.
A shining phoenix also replaces the shooting
star that normally arcs over the castle.
A nice touch given Mulan's connection with
the mythological beast in the new movie.
The shapeshifting sorceress, played by Gong
Li, is a cool new character added to this
version of the story.
And in her very first scene we get a hint
at how her arc will parallel Mulan's,
as she disguises herself by merging with the
body of a man on the Silk Road,
just like our heroine will later pretend to
be a man in order to join the Imperial army.
The sorceress's name Xianniang as well as
her character arc are also hat-tips to a 17th-century
Chinese novel in which a princess of the same
name captured Mulan,
but then they became bonded sisters when Mulan
revealed her true identity to her.
In Disney's movie, although Mulan and the
sorceress start out as enemies, they gain
respect for one another and ultimately become
allies.
Although the sorceress can shapeshift into
various forms, she frequently turns into a
hawk and so resembles Shan Yu's falcon side-kick
from the animated movie.
And there are loads of incredible hawk-like
details on her costume, from her long feather-like
skirt.
to her belt made from bones;
and then there's her fearsome-looking hawk
crown.
She also has talon-shaped daggers that she
can toss with deadly force;
and she can even grow bird-like claws on her
fingers that she uses to slash at her enemies.
"I could tear you to pieces before you blink."
Plus, according to the film's director Niki
Caro,
her "makeup [is] hooded like a hawk's in the
form of a white mask,"
with the use of the colour white being significant
because in China
"white [is] the color of death [and] also
the color of purity".
Ming-Na Wen, the voice of the animated Mulan,
makes an awesome cameo to the tune of Reflection
as she presents her live-action counterpart
to the emperor:
"Your imperial highness.
Hua Mulan."
Ming-Na Wen's official credit in the movie
is "Esteemed Guest" which is a lovely way
to acknowledge the legacy of the original
Disney film that the new movie builds upon.
If you look at the train of her dress really
closely you can spot a phoenix, another nice
detail connecting both Disney Mulans together.
More on the other hidden phoenixes and their
true meaning in the movie later.
And the green and red colours of Ming Na Wen's
ceremonial dress also appear to be a nod to
the colours of the outfit that the animated
Mulan wore in front of the emperor,
as well as the various shades of green she
wore during the animation.
Everyone's favourite animated talking dragon
Mushu may not have made it in to the live-action
movie;
but the filmmakers still wanted to honour
him by including ancestral dragons in the
film,
and you'll find them on various fabrics and
weapons.
So watch the scene closely when Mulan's father
goes to sharpen his the family sword, because
the stone he uses is wrapped in a cloth with
an embroidered picture of a dragon.
Also during Mulan's confrontation with the
sorceress, you can spot a dragon on the guard
of Mulan's ancestral sword.
And then there's a dragon on the hilt of the
sword that's gifted to Mulan by the emperor
at the end of the movie.
There's also a sneaky nod to one of Mushu's
most memorable lines from the animated movie
when the garrison sergeant tells the troops
what will befall them if they are found being
dishonest:
"Disgrace.
Disgrace for you.
Disgrace for your family.
Disgrace for your village.
Disgrace for your country."
"All right, that's it!
Dishonor!
Dishonor on your whole family.
Make a note of this.
Dishonor on you, dishonor on your cow.."
And Mulan's new mythological guardian, the
phoenix, is predominantly red, yellow and
purple, a hat tip to Mushu's colours in the
90s classic.
Another of Mulan's animated side-kicks was
Cri-Kee, the allegedly lucky cricket.
Like Mushu, Cri-Kee doesn't appear in the
new movie;
however, there is a human character called
Cricket that joins the army at the same time
as Mulan.
"I'm Cricket.
My mother says that I was born under an auspicious
moon."
"Yep, this cricket's a lucky one!"
Cricket does seem to have good fortune.
Despite all of the new recruits being terrible
archers, he's able to hit the target even
with his eyes closed.
And he gets an awesome moment protecting Mulan
and clearing a path for her when he takes
out two Rouran soldiers with one lucky shot
from his bow.
Like the animated Cri-Kee, he also miraculously
survives a potentially fatal accident during
the avalanche scene.
"Man, you are one lucky bug."
And again during the final showdown at the
Imperial City, to everyone's relief we discover
Cricket really does enjoy good fortune just
like his animated counterpart also survived
the final battle.
"You are a lucky bug."
And fun fact: if you didn't already know,
crickets are viewed as symbols of good fortune
in China and were kept as pets from early
antiquity;
however, Cri-Kee was so unpopular among many
of Disney Animation's filmmakers at the time
of the original film, that he almost ended
up scrapped from the movie.
The ever-so-memorable musical numbers from
the animation didn't make it into the live-action
version, but there are still numerous references
to the iconic songs.
The popular "I'll Make A Man Out of You" is
referenced when the garrison's sergeant says:
"We're going to make men out of every single
one of you."
That's followed by a training montage that
pays homage to the scene that accompanied
the song in the animation.
For example, when the recruits miserably fail
to get anywhere near the targets with their
bow and arrow, it's very similar to the original
film.
They also have to carry heavy pails of water
up a mountain, similar to the weights they
were made to carry in the animation.
In the new movie, this bucket challenge replaces
the pole climb,
and unlike the animated Mulan who struggled
carrying weights up the mountain,
this new challenge is the one where she shines
and proves her worth.
The interesting difference here is that it's
Mulan's chi that powers her up the mountain,
whereas in the animation it was her ingenuity
and determination in figuring out how to repurpose
the weights that helped her scale the log.
At the heart of both the live-action and animated
Mulan movies is the idea of being true to
who you really are.
The song "Reflection" is a core part of that
theme in the animation, and the new movie
pays tribute to that with an instrumental
version which plays at key moments.
So, when Mulan is summoned to her commanding
officer, as he begins to explain how "only
the most true connect [to their] chi", the
tune from "Reflection" is woven into the music
playing in the background.
The moment is not only a great easter egg,
but it also adds an extra emotional layer
to the scene,
with "Reflection" continuing to play over
the montage of Mulan learning to reconnect
with her chi;
and finishing as she reaches the summit of
the mountain.
And that montage also includes several visual
nods to when the animated Mulan sang the song
for the first time,
as the camera lingers over her reflection
in the water and also over a nearby magnolia
tree.
There's also a second musical reference during
this sequence with a shout-out to a line from
"I'll Make A Man Out of You" when Commander
Tung says:
"Tranquil as a forest...
but on fire within."
You'll also hear "Reflection" during Mulan's
next big moment which comes just after her
confrontation with the sorceress, when Hua
Jun dies and the true Mulan is born.
As she looks into her sword, she sees her
own reflection together with the word "true",
and then the instrumental theme strikes up
again as she sheds her false identity and
reveals her true self.
The theme of "Reflection" and being true to
yourself is even carried into the very final
scene of the new movie
when Mulan looks into the blade of her new
sword and sees herself and the phoenix reflected
back at her.
This is in sharp contrast to the start of
the film just before she meets the matchmaker
when she looks in the mirror and sees a version
of herself that doesn't reflect who she really
is.
Another shout-out to the animated movie comes
at the garrison when Ling looks at a scroll
of a girl, which recalls how the song "A Girl
Worth Fighting For" started off in the animation.
"That's what I said.
A girl worth fighting for."
And when the men start discussing who their
ideal woman would be, Po says
"I don't care what she looks like."
"I agree."
"I care what she cooks like."
Very similar to what was said in the animated
movie.
I couldn't care less what she'll wear or what
she looks like.
It all depends on what she cooks like."
The embarrassing moment for Mulan when she
enters the tent and Po drops his towel
is a humorous call-back to the animation's
lake scene when Mulan had to avert her eyes
after Yao climbed onto a rock stark naked.
"I am Yao!
King of the rock!
And there's nothin' you girls can do about
it."
And there's a short instrumental version of
the song "Honor To Us All" when Mulan is primped
and polished to go to the matchmaker, in tribute
to the original film.
The magnolia tree by the lake in the live-action
movie and the blossoms that the camera focuses
on when Mulan goes to bathe
are a sweet call-back to the magnolia tree
from the animated film and a crucial moment
in that story when Mulan's father told her
"This one's late.
But I'll bet that when it blooms,
it will be the most beautiful of all."
Mulan's name actually means magnolia in Chinese
which is why the flower is so thematically
important in both the Disney movies.
For example, the film's costume designer added
a large embroidered magnolia blossom to the
centre of the undergarment Mulan wears as
part of her matchmaker outfit.
And when she practises her sword work and
learns to connect with her chi, she does so
near the magnolia tree by the lake.
Mulan's matchmaker outfit also has embroidered
images of the phoenix which are a nice nod
to the crucial role the mythological beast
plays for our heroine in this version of the
story.
The choice to use a phoenix as Mulan's guardian
in the new movie is especially interesting
because, as we see in the emperor's throne
room, the phoenix sits to his right while
the dragon sits to his left.
And, of course, Mulan's journey takes her
to the Imperial City where she saves his life.
In China, the phoenix has often been viewed
as a symbol of the empress or a female member
of the royal family while the dragon represented
the emperor,
with the two together representing a harmonious
and balanced relationship.
In addition to that, in Chinese mythology
the phoenix was originally two separate birds,
one male and one female, though they later
merged to become one.
And so the duality of the phoenix makes it
a perfect guardian and symbol for Mulan who
as a woman takes on what's perceived to be
a traditionally male role in the story.
And there are also so many call-backs and
little twists on moments from the original
movie.
One of my favourites is when Mulan returns
to the army to deliver news about Böri Khan's
secret plan to attack the Imperial City.
Commander Tung says it's foolish to listen
to her given she was dishonest about who she
really was, to which Honghui replies:
"You would believe Hua Jun,
why do you not believe Hua Mulan?"
It's a line that echoes what Mulan said in
her own defence in the animated movie.
"You said you'd trust Ping.
Why is Mulan any different?"
Then when she faces off against Böri Khan
without a sword and uses her skills and smarts
to take it from him,
it's a call-back to how she used her quick-thinking
to wrangle Shan Yu's sword from him defeating
him in the animation.
"Looks like you're all out of ideas."
"Not quite."
And the single soldier who survives Böri
Khan's attack at the beginning of the film
and delivers the news of the defeat to the
Imperial City
"This soldier is the only survivor."
is a throw-back to how Shan Yu decided only
one man was needed to send his message to
the emperor.
"How many men does it take to deliver a message?"
"One."
As well as Disney easter eggs, the new movie
also includes a few shout-outs to the original
Ballad of Mulan that the story is based on.
When the adult Mulan arrives home at the beginning
of the film, she tells her parents about two
rabbits that were running alongside her while
she was out riding:
"I think one was a male, one was a female.
But you know you can't really tell when they
are running that fast."
Mulan's comment isn't just a reference to
the theme of gender roles in the story;
it's also a nice hat-tip to the original ballad
which ends with the lines:
"Two rabbits running close to the ground,
How can they tell if I am male or female?"
And when we see Mulan's little sister busy
at the loom at the start of the film, it's
a nod to how the original poem starts off
with Mulan herself weaving at a loom.
I really liked some of the bold creative choices
in the new movie and in my other Mulan video
I do a deep dive into the best and worst differences
in the live-action film compared to Disney's
animation.
Tap here to watch that next or follow the
link in the video description.
So, did you spot any other easter eggs or
interesting details in the new movie?
And what were your favourite moments?
Comment with your thoughts below.
If you enjoyed this don't forget to leave
a thumbs-up.
It really helps and I hugely appreciate it.
Tap left for my full Mulan and Disney live-action
playlist or tap right for something else you're
sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!